الاتراك يستفيقون على هزه جديده فجر اليوم
والحصيله تتجاوز اربعه الاف وثمانمائه في
تركيا وسوريا
الدفاع المدني في سوريا يوجه نداء استغاثه
لانقاذ مئات العائلات السوريه تحت الانقاض
في شمال غرب البلاد
الولايات المتحده والصين وروسيا تضع
خلافاتها جانبا وتهرع لمساعده ضحايا زلزال
في تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا النشره من تركيا
حيث لا تزال البلاد تشهدها الفداديه تقض
مظاجع الاتراك زلزال الامس هو الاشد منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه في هذا السياق
مشاهدينا اعلنا مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبي
عن هزه جديده بقوه خمس درجات فاصله سته
على ضربت وسط تركيا صباح اليوم من جهتها
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
اباد ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلازل الذي بل
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي البلاد الى ثلاثه
الى ثلاثه الاف وثلاثمائه قتيلا هو عدد
المصابين الى عشرين الفا وعشرين
قتل
2921 من مواطنين عدد الجرح لدينا هو
15,834 كانت هناك طلبات مساعده ودعم من 65
دوله حتى الان وسننقل هذه الفرق الدوليه
الى مناطق الكوارث عندما يصلون تماشيا مع
الخطط المعمول بها
وكما نطلع على الشاشه بحسب مصد السوري
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في سوريا الى 1500
قتيلا فرق الانقاذ تركيا مشاهدينا تواصل
عمليه البحث عن ناجين وكما نتابع الان في
هذه الصور المباشره من تركيا حيث تتواصل
عمليات الانقاذ من قبل فرق الانقاذ للبحث
عن ناجيين بين انقاض المباني التي انهارت
بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا الاجماليه مشاهديها لعدد
القتلى في البلدين تجاوزت
4800 بعد هزات ارضيه عنيفه ضربت مناطق
قريبه اذا من الحدود التركيه السوريه بلغت
قوتها سبعه درجات فاصله ثمانيه اليوم كانت
هناك ايضا هزه صباح اليوم بلغت قوتها خمسه
درجات فاصله سته اداره الكوارث التركيه
مشاهدينا اكدت ايضا ارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال في تركيا الى ثلاثه الاف
وثلاثمائه واحد وثمانين والجرحى الى عشرين
الف واربعمائه وسته وعشرين فرق دراسه
التركيه مشاهدين ايضا احصت انهيار اكثر من
خمسه
الاف600 مبنى في العديد من المدن بينها
مباني من طوابق عده تضم عائلات كبيره كان
افرادها نياما عندما ضرب زلزال الاول
مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات البحث عن المفقودين تحت الانقاض
في منطقه ديار بكر في تركيا هناك مخالف
مشاه ان يستمر عدد القتلى في الارتفاع
بهذه الوتيره خاصه وان تقديرات منظمه
الصحه العالميه تشير الى ان قرابه 20 الف
شخص ربما يكونوا قد لقوه مصرعهم وذلك بحسب
تقديرات منظمه الصحه العالميه اما في
انحاء سوريا مشاهدينا فقد قتل تقريبا
789 شخصا على الاقل وذلك بحسب وزاره صحه
النظام وايضا بعض فرق الاغاثه الجزائر
مشاهدينا لطلب مناطق في سوريا تركز اكثر
بخسائر كبيره ايضا في محافظات كل من حلب
واللاذقيه وحماه وكذلك في طرطوس وريف ادلب
ويشار الى ان الزلزال الاول وقع يوم
الاثنين على عمق نحو 19 كيلومترا فاصله
تسعه وذلك وفق المعهد الامريكي للمسح
الجيولوجي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تركيا منذ عام 1500 تعرضت لنحو ثلاثه
وعشرين زلزالا مدمرا لكن زلزال اليوم امس
كان الاقوى منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
منذ عام 1500 شهيد التركي نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 20300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمصرع ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
[موسيقى]
بين نار الحرب وبروده فصل الشتاء يعيش
السوريون شمال البلاد هذه الايام على وقع
هزات زلزال عنيف لم يترك لهم سقفا يغطيهم
اوضاع السوريين كانت سيئه لكنها اليوم
اسوا مع هذا الزلزال الذي خلف حتى الان
واقتل
1580 وفق اخر تحديث من المرسل السوري
بحقوق الانسان الصحه السوريه مشاهدينا
افادت في حاصله غير نهائيه بمقتل
789 شخصا في طرطوس وحلب اللاذقيه ادلب
وحماه من جهاته اشد الدفاع المدني السوري
تقديم المساعده لانقاذ مئات العائلات
السوريه تحت الانقاض في شمال غرب البلاد
جراء الزلزال المتمر
هذا واظهرت لقطات محاوله فرق الانقاذ
مساعده العالقين تحت الانقاض وتقديم
المساعده اللازمه في بلده الاتارب في حلب
الغربي بعد زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
كما اظهر مقطع فيديو بلده عزمارين في ريف
حلب سوريا حيث تبدو المنازل وقد سويت
بالارض بفعل زلزال القوي
من القميص المشاهدين مراسل العربيه جماعه
كاش اهلا بك جمعه وتفاصيل اوفى حول اخر
المعلومات حول عمليات الانقاذ
واعداد الضحايا ايضا
يعني منذ صباح اليوم وحتى الان قامت فرق
الانقاذ المدني في مناطق المعارضه وفرق
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري مع الويه من
الجيش
والبلديات في مناطق اللاذقيه
وحلب وطرطوس بانقاذ نحو 100 شخص يعني تم
انقاذ حوالي 100 شخص من تحت الانقاذ عبر
جميع يعني فرق الانقاذ والجهود
الجهود الخاصه بالمعارضه والنظام اسفلت عن
انقاذ حوالي 100 شخص من تحت الارقام لكن
لا يزال حتى الان المئات من
العائلات عالقه تحت ركام المنازل في في
مدن اللاذقيه
ادلب وحلب وطرطوس بدا الوقت ينفذ من هذه
العائلات في ظل ظروف الطقس السيئه ودرجه
يعني يعني والبروده الكبيره يعني حتى نسمع
نداءات من الاهالي من الناشطين من
الاعلاميين من يعني الجهات المعنيه بانقاذ
هؤلاء بان الوقت بدا ينفذ امام المئات من
العائلات وقد تتضاءل امامهم فرص البقاء
على قيد الحياه لان الامكانيات خاصه في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا امكانيات بسيطه
وتكاد تكون يعني غير يعني غير مناسبه
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الازمات خاصه نحن
نتحدث عن مباني ضخمه تهدمت على رؤوس
قاطنيها لا تملك فرق الدفاع المدني سوى
بعض العائله الاليات لرفع الانقاذ
وجرفها هناك مثلا في مدينه جنديرس 84 مبنى
يعني هبطت على رؤوسه هل من مساعدات خارجيه
او داخليه بدات تصل الى مناطق الشمال
السوري او شمال غرب سوريا يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك طائرتان عراقيتان هبطتها في
مطار دمشق الدولي تحملان حوالي 70 طن من
المواد الاغاثيه والطبيه
والبطانيات ايضا طائره ايرانيه تحمل
مساعدات لوجستيان غير ذلك لا توجد اي
مساعدات هذه المساعدات ستصل الى مناطق
سيطره النظام خاصه في اللاذقيه وطرطوس
والجزء الواقع تحت سيطرته في مدينه حلب
بينما حتى الان لم تدخل اي مساعد
الانسانيه الى شمال غرب حلب حيث مناطق
نفوز المعارضه لا من مناطق سيطره ولا حتى
من معبر باب الهوى مع مع تركيا لذلك الوضع
الانساني في هذه البقعه الجغرافيه وضع
ماساوي نعم اذا الناميه القميص اللي كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه جمعه كاش شكرا لك جمعه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
نتيجه التصدع جدار السجن حروب عشرين عنصرا
من داعش من سجن راجو السوري
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افادت مصادر
السوريه بفرار عشرين نزيلا على الاقل من
سجن راجو شمال غرب سوريا بينهم سجناء من
تنظيم داعش وتاتي عمليه الفرار بعد تنفيذ
عصيان داخل السجن افرازال الذي ضرب مناطق
في سوريا واسفر عن تصدع جدران السجن
التابع لفصائل مواجهه لتركيا في بلده راجو
قرب الحدود التركيه ويضم السجن نحو
الفيسجن ينتمي معظمهم لتنظيم داعش
من القاهره مشاهدينا ينضم الينا رامي عبد
الرحمن مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
ما هي المعلومات المتوفره لكم حول ما حدث
ومصير هؤلاء السجناء الذين فروا منتظم
داعش
نعم صباح الخير يعني اولا ليسوا جميعهم
الذين فروا الى محيط المنطقه هم من سجناء
موجودين في هذا الفجل السيء السبعه والسيد
حقيقه الامر يوجد فيه نعم مئات السجناء من
ابناء عفرين الذين ينشرون في تلك المنطقه
وقبل العام الفائز مفصل عن هذا السجن
السجن كل من يدخل اليه يجب ان يخرج منه
بعد دفع اقاوه ماليه للفصيل المسؤول عن
هذا السجل بانه في حال هناك هروب لعناصر
من داعش مقابل مبلغ مالي لان لماذا لم
يهرب
ويجب ان يفتح حقيقه الامر النظام اذا لم
يفتح النظام الباب لتصل مساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه فالنظام عديم الاخلاق حقيقه
الامر لان الوضع الانساني اليوم يحكم على
الجميع ان يبتعد عن السياسه يبتعد عن
العسكره وتفتح البوابات على مصراعيها او
ما تعرف بالمعابر ما بين النظام وبين
المعارضه وما بين مناطق السيطره التركيه
للوصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها وهنا نقول
بان هناك مساعدات عربيه ستصل مساعدات من
دول يعني من الصين من دول اخرى ستصل الى
دمشق يجب ان توزع عبر جمعيات ولا توزع عبر
النظام نريد من هذه المساعدات بالفعل ان
تصل الى مستحقيها ولا تصل الى يعني بعض
الفاسدين في النظام الان الوضع
بامتياز الخسائر البشريه في ارتفاع
العالقين تحت الانقاد والذين ايضا شردوا
بالمنازلهم لا يوجد لديهم ماوى لا يوجد
يعني مساعدات طبيه مساعدات غذائيه مساعدات
لوجستيه يجب ان تصل الى مستحقيها يعني
مستحقيها هو فقط محض امنيات حتى اللحظه لم
يحدث شيء على الارض نعم على الاطلاق على
الاطلاق هذاك التي يعني كل ما جرى الان في
سوريا الامس الى اليوم هي مساعدات اهليه
ليست مساعدات خارجيه وصلت الى تلك المناطق
وفرق الانقاذ تعمل ليلا نهارا من اجل
محاوله انقاص واخراج بعض المدنيين
العالقين تحت الانقاذ الذين لا يسالون على
قيد الحياه امس تحدثنا عن 58 بلده ومدينه
وقريه اليوم ضمن الاحصائيات 72 مدينه
وبلده وقريه تضررت نتيجه هذا الزلزال وكان
فيها ضحايا سواء في محافظات حلب ادلب حماه
طرطوس اللاذقيه اي ان المصاب كبير لابناء
الشعب السوري والامر لا يحتاج الى تسييف
لا يحتاج الى فرقه هذه المساعدات يحتاج
لاغاثه ابناء الشعب السوري الذين لديهم
كارثه انسانيه كبيره في هذه المنطقه نعم
القاهره كنت معنا رامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان تحياتي
مشاهدينا الزلزال المدمر الذي هز تركيا
وسوريا حرك ايضا مبدا التضامن الانساني
ودفع كبار العالم مثل الولايات المتحده
والصين وروسيا الى وضع خلافاتهم جانبا
والتركيز على اغاثه مانكوبي زلزال في هذا
الاطار المشاهدين اجر الرئيس الامريكي
اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لتقديم التعازي وتجديد التاكيد
على استعداد واشنطن للمساعده في جهود
الانقاذ بعد زلزال وقال البيت الابيض ان
الفرق الامريكيه انتشرت بشكل سريع لدعم
جهود البحث والانقاذ التركيه
من جهتها قالت وسائل الاعلام الصينيه ان
بكيه ستقدم دفعه اولى قدرها خمسه ملايين
وتسعمائه الف دولار كمساعدات طارئه لجهود
الاغاثه في تركيا بعد الزلزال الكبير الذي
ضرب البلاد هذا الاسبوع واضافت ان الصليب
الاحمر الصيني سيقدم مساعده طارئه قيمتها
200 الف دولار لكل من تركيا وسوريا
بدورها افادت وزاره حالات الطوارئ الروسيه
بان اكثر من 100 رجل انقاذ وصلوا الى
تركيا للمساعده في اعمال الاغاثه هذا وتم
نشر مستشفى متنقل في منطقه الطوارئ
بالاضافه الى فريق بحث مع كلاب مدربه
ومعدات لاعمال البحث وزاره حاله الطوارئ
اوضحت ان رجال الانقاذ الروس وصلوا الى
اكثر الى اكثر المناطق تضررا وهي كهرمان
مرعش
يؤكد استعداد منظمه الامم المتحده لدعم
جهود الاستجابه الطارئه بعيدا وجهت فريقي
للتنسيق مع تركيا وتوفير المساعدات
اللازمه
بوتين مستعدون للمساعده في القضاء على
تدعيه الكارثه
ماكرون فرنسا مستعده لتوفير مساعده عاجله
للسكان في تركيا وسوريا اسرائيل تعرض
ارسال فرق بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى تركيا
وسوريا
المانيا تعهدت بتقديم مساعدات شامله
لضحايا الزلزال عبر كل الوسائل المتاحه
ايطاليا بدات بالفعل في تجهيز فرق الانقاذ
التي ستسافر الى تركيا
تعلن استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات انسانيه
عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا
هذا وافادت وكاله الانباء السعوديه بان
ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان
قدم التعازي هاتفيا للرئيس التركي رجب
اردوغان في ضحايا الزلزال واكد الامير
محمد بن سلمان وقوف السعوديه ومساندتها
لتركيا لتجاوز هذه الكاره الطبيعيه بدوره
اعرب اردوغان عن تقديره لوقوف السعوديه
الى جانب تركيا في هذا الظرف الصعب
العناوين
الاتراك يستفقون على هزه جديده فجر اليوم
والحصيله تتجاوز
4,800 قتيل في تركيا وسوريا
الدفاع المدني في سوريا يوجه نداء استغاثه
لانقاذ مئات العائله السوريه تحت الانقاض
في شمال غرب البلاد
الولايات المتحده والصين وروسيا تضع
خلافاتها جانبا وتهرع لمساعده ضحايا
الزلزال في كل من تركيا وسوريا
نهايه هذه النشره مشاهدينا في امان الله
[موسيقى]